a New York Times blockbuster raising
even more questions about the timing as
well as the motivation for Donald
Trump's sudden firing of James Comey the
FBI director days before the firing of
Comey which was about 48 hours ago James
Comey went to the Justice Department to
ask for more money for the investigation
into Trump Russia collusion according to
multiple congressional officials
including Senator Dick Durbin the
Justice Department is run by Attorney
General Jeff Sessions who after lying
about multiple meetings with Russian
ambassador Sergei kis lyac said he would
be recusing himself from anything
relating to Russia this is the same Jeff
Sessions who according to the letter
from Trump explaining the firing of
James Comey recommended that James Comey
be fired red alert we need an
independent prosecutor the guy who said
Jeff Sessions that he would not get
involved in anything Russia related
because he lied about Russian meetings
is the same guy running the department
that was asked for more money to
investigate his boss Trump and Russia
and then was cited as the person who
recommended the firing of the person
running the investigation and adding to
the strange circumstances is that the
Department of Justice is saying oh Comey
asked for more money no those reports
are totally false which to believe at
this point would require believing that
there's yet another conspiracy to
concoct lies out of thin air which is a
bit too big of a pill to swallow right
now and now Ron Wyden who is a
democratic senator from Oregon is
calling for the resignation of Jeff
Sessions because he promised the country
he was going to stay out of this Russia
probe yeah we do need a special
prosecutor only problem with that is
that would have to go through Congress
and then Trump would have to sign off on
it yeah so that's a big task getting
through it all in Congress and then the
guy who has the investigation against
him would have to sign off on it I don't
see that closed loop it's a totally
closed loop of lack of independence and
obviously the timing of the money
requests alone isn't proof that the
firing of Comey was about Russia the
recommendation from jeff Sessions isn't
proof the fact that Comey was going to
testify today about Trump Russia isn't
proof the Sally Yates testimony on
Monday blowing the story wide open it's
not proof none of it's proof but it all
looks pretty
damn bad I guess it's just all
coincidence pad these are just mere
coincidences
oh yeah the Trump team asserts that this
had nothing to do with the Russia probe
it was entirely because of James commis
treatment of Hillary Clinton and the
email investigation circumventing the
chain of command with all that stuff who
could believe that at this point who
could believe that only the most
committed ideologue and anyone expecting
James commis firing to be the straw that
breaks the camel's back so to speak
don't be so sure there are people all
over the media congratulating Trump on
the firing turn on Fox News Sean Hannity
talking about just how great it is this
is all an insult to the intelligence of
clear-thinking people but lots of Trump
is still don't want to see the obvious
and I believe we are maybe going to see
an avalanche of leaks and leakers
starting very soon when will the country
be up in arms about this this is a good
time I read this morning about some
protests demanding an investigation into
the firing of James Comey itself smoking
gun we talked about there are smoking
guns after smoking guns its resembling
Nixon more and more and what we have to
remember here is that if Trump is
impeached which is not looking
particularly likely given who would have
to start that impeachment process if
Mike Pence becomes the president it will
get really boring and arguably a result
as a result more damaging to the country
because of all the things Mike Pence
would be able to do as a committed
right-wing ideologue that would not make
headlines in the way that Trump's
craziness makes headlines that's true
and possibly you know we're going down
the road here but it's all on Trump gets
impeached it's not too far off to think
that Mike Pence would as well because
pence joined the Trump campaign in July
you'd have to think there would be some
overlap there with the flash' ties oh
there's no doubt that pence is just as
involved in the Russia stuff and know it
knows about it as anybody else but in
the hypothetical you have to at least
consider the possibility that Mike Pence
becomes president of the u.s.